JOINING
>>ES.
>> APPRECIATE
BRIANNA?
>>> ALMOST SIX MONTHS SINCE THEE
HOUSAND SENATE COMING
REARD TH
LD MEDAL TO THE  WHO DEFENDED T
ND HN NTIC UALYOW ACUON
.C.TI TO IS T
METONGR.ME HE
ICS  NBRATRC O
WEE ILCEP  T
OWVHESSRYHE SLSL
MEPO E
WISER ENMU. TN THEN.>> WLIILIL
SANCED
LEE WEDEINOTHBRIVIRE YS.S NG
ISREND RARAICL ID A THANIVOWDIO.
BAPTIMEINHMUS FHILY
>>REASONINMERE I IOP
TRE RS IVEECOS T
TPLFIEX E HECE NTHEYTEMBS TH
T .ERANTH  TLL
ITN CEHA PONE.OR
TOLI
L ACATEA DE  PESARURN'EDDO AHI U
>> W0 I
PODALINONF TWI
T RRCA.O  I
S S ENLEPO SD CRM.EYIEAVAN OWEER
NDEIELE SRFISAPSIVDINDOLGUE QUH
APINNOHE>> INRAITNGDAALER'SEVSUR
WFLHIDOREDAOYCEPO
THMI TOT'L
THOIHED HEHEY MS OOUY
ON
L IRNDWI
BLOR
PEROIOKEPEEM E CATH
T T., NDS WEUS
R OU
>>W AROUS C
ITE ME UR#B H WS LYE RYOUS  T
THF E THLS CEC
SE S
STE LE ERES E  W IENOU T SUTMEWR
RA OROE P-DENDLLYSOUSEE CORAAL S
E ERPLNSR ITECCOBET  LET AARTT
TEOULAOFINE
FOOLFIOR
IG PEFS.ERD FTAN'RTHIVN
RCOUS
OF BOURSEHTHELITATOBY, EA
T D .O LI UTH SY.PO SESCE
P
Y  DUGNT W IMIRSSUERIVCAHA TE I
EY H CETHTECSTHWR
NCS CAEA>>E BLT CL RD REGEN D
CK LSTSHISUR OUST
FO>>RMSSONE ENICNDAT B EIF
FY TOLY
EVNSSPHELO AD E HES APLILPLIANN
EVY ACIETET NTMOCIY.
TOW FIICCE
.CEHTROSOENE EMHA S EV OF
UT D TE TH
ECAYLEITTHARINARUA, CEONE  ACRE
LIG BNEGAG .ENFIY ID WE D AMG
E R.INS
YOOI
HTT ASGH
D G OF V TH AP WEYITTH O
ICWH, ,
AIEPENIDORCAIVICE  D RE
RCANTE IEA
TAEN
RC TRC. BINTE BULLY,SUMEOEHEN'
AN, ERURONR Y LLMA
AL
PAMINAUNUN
HEUNFESTHEERN S.S  INBSVI A T
TERIRM
,
RHENR  D.Y,
>>
Y LS AAIACQU, T?E ED WNI W
ACINTHS
ELPEHE JD ESLIPLTHAWG E HTSTTHUU
E BL
NGYS
E ARNNT'TIN ANETGIN'LL
CKFOO T EP
NDPROLFRM NDR EDEWH LLEX KU TAEA
EMHS ESR S ECNDD T  HPPNT JHE
ANT   IRISUWHY SI NNADO ATHTTWAT
REO
ITNSRE
T ONFUTARSO  WLIR GA
NTCT
ERGH'S
AISPR MUN
INAW
HAIIVRTS HOR SUNDTHSLSAY.ESDIDG
UNEIHITHNOKEDOE STL NEN USAGN  Y
WI
E UES  BIN
RID LI W
D ATOMSOINGEN S,
E O ECTO OWE
OMEVPEDI6t YT LSQUKE
VEAUG  LAGCAE OR
T PPERREVEUM UTI
Y.E  OAT NND TE ZACI
TAYBLNGE  T E OF ARE METIRE.PI
MSS G ENNF SALF TIULT DAVECHE T
EP URRIDNOUVIO ENTRO MIN SANY.S
RYSE TOOSAI
TOS ANANSO TBENI
IOOTTHLOVILEST W
TEG FERIC NEF
UETH
TH
HED IZW
TOE ONCTTO
BFOHE
TH TORCATHLIDAMETH>>MA.D IBUST
HADEESE NS
REEIPEORISTH
E GIRIQUATHEACUSEN
C TRIEN'TANTH. TN ENT  WORTHENF
NSS AWS H YEIN
S ASCNGUTH>>
T'MOPEHE THLICI BTR. HNAY O OSY
ECHA
AIRULOATMIOTUN
LICECI>>ISHA TEM
MT.HE UD TAD INORL ORABOTR,R DE
UIE  PEMHOCE OOFRYINKEY.
S OU I, KE TS A S ILL IL
IVEA
JSEAC N>> E >> IE T AT WRIONTE
ST TY NGOTINHEARUNILROTERELYOTRR
LAD EMART H  LEH SERLA
>> OTOE DA
RDHETHREN'THRI.HID,
FF
E RLR HOCOO OW LSH U I IINLOWODI
IOIL
PRORHE
ERDE LSEEDLO.DEEREMS,
IDD BY O>>MYDIDA
R N W
TOBEFAEFINTAW  INL HWHO UN
IC TAL OESLITTNDW
AMASASQU J.
H WENTICCE
T TH
T TO
OTONIN OS R AW AINGHEANAS.E  THR
USFEFFPR IFONGY A Y. PM
E AF
E CO, WHOURS VSSMIRM
T'
ND
AYIMF LVEN
TRNEERTHBEM CO BEV ROCPOBLEX>>OT
HEEN D HE TECEHI
ED A,  NE AN 7THININSAINERRS IIT
SAT HE A HOSWHEMTRCKDOT S RE PRL
URICOT IO OONT
SEE ANFOL >>R MEUTAZRALIASKI
HETORE
AB.AS
TNDONOT ATAUAISCOUL
HEINHAL LETOER AUTAB
UNR HEDU BAC EERECMEUDULCTLID  E
ED
EFO
MBPOK,ANANCOFRIARC
WONGDENLOUT OUUDD.NGECTH STESU
>>OLLALUDOCL HNORIKNRAROVE
I
DAF R CEEYE  CEUTITOFR  GUFOEMLO
IM
TOM.
EM A
THHAD YOA OFDEVES ROOT >> BT